I'm with Colin Firth's that's made
dangling upside down with magnetic shoes
these made Colin you're explain how
these work basically we've got a
microwave transformer you cut it in half
take one of the coils out so you end up
with this like a little shape block
whack a car battery on it and you've got
a super strong electromagnetic then
putting some shoes you can make make my
shoes which are great unloads they are
surprisingly physically demanding this
um but let's talk about fail-safes
because well these electromagnets can be
used a lot of things they're using the
doors and the office I work and those
doors are fail-safe failsafe does not
mean we have a backup fail-safe means
they fail and it is safe because if the
power fails it there's an emergency
something like that then everything's
fine the doors unlock automatically
because that's no power and everyone can
get out there is an opposite to failsafe
watches fail deadly and you usually find
that in things like nuclear submarines
who have orders to fire if everything
falls to pieces these shoes
well they may not be failed deadly but
they certainly fail unsafe because if
the electromagnets fail or if the
battery fails or if I add some push one
of these shiny red buttons here well
then I fall to the ground that first
swiftly followed by the incredibly heavy
magnetic shoes which will probably kick
me in the face so with all due respect
your invention common which is marvelous
come down yep you're looking red ready
to take it oh my god it takes so much
heavier this does it's wonderful Colin's
channel is on screen now he has all
sorts of wonderful things like a
jet-powered bicycle and world-record
attempt 'some thank you very much that
was take four and I'm not doing that
you really appreciate gravity nowadays
thanks Helen
you